par le pouvoir que me confèrent le
conseil intergalactique des espèces
supérieurs je prononce l'ordre d'entamer
la destruction immédiate de la planète
des tests habituels cagni un seul t rien
sera sélectionné au hasard
il devra choisir de se servir de son
pouvoir absolu pour faire le bien
espérons aussi essentiel pour faire le
mal la terre sera anéantie
imagine que tu puisses faire une seule
chose qu'ils amélioraient radicalement
d'avis en séquences il voir ma voisine
catherine depuis chez moi
je provoque des événements vêtements
habillés mois il suffit que j'agis
camarades délice parle comme un humain
biscuits quoi des biscuits a laissé
tomber s'il te plaît y a que ça qui
compte
j'aimerais bien aussi [ __ ] ta jambe là
tout de suite je pourrais résoudre tous
les problèmes de l'humanité tu es sûr
que tu as bien réfléchi crottes de
chiens nettoyez vous il est évident
qu'il n'a aucune intention d'utiliser
son pouvoir pour faire le bien
donnez moi un corps remarquable et une
et berne grata au départ si l'ordre de 5
millions je me suis montré égoïste je
peux apporter le bonheur que tous ceux
qui sont morts reviennent à la fia
cela fait deux mois le président des
états unis
j'ai ici les débriefings de washington
pour la syrie le déficit qui sera elle
et le moyen-orient attention
sonnette senet fait semblant d'être
chiant ordinaire tu dois faire des
disques donnez-moi le corps d'un homme
remarquable c'est quoi